قبل الحصاد كنت اجريت مقابله مع منسقه
الامم المتحده الخاصه بلبنان وسالتها اولا
ان كان للامم المتحده اي تصورا بشان حل
المشاكل السياسيه والاقتصاديه للبنان
على هذا السؤال اسمحوا لي ان ابدا بفكره
بسيطه وهي ان لبنان لديه موارد بشريه
كامله كثيره والشعب لديه مهارات كبيره
ويستطيع ان يبني مستقبل البلاد الى املوا
ان يتخذوا القرارات المناسبه في المستقبل
ونحن في الامم المتحده طبعا موجودونا على
الارض فهناك النحو 26 وكاله تابعه للامم
المتحده وقوات حفظ السلام اليونيفيل ما هو
مطلوب اليوم حسب رايي هو تنفيذ وتطبيق
الاصلاحات الضروريه واستئناف المفاوضات مع
صندوق النقد الدولي تحتاج كذلك ان يكون
لبنان مستقرا ويعمل كدوله فيها مؤسسات
فاعله وجيده وهنا سيكون انتخاب رئيس جديد
وتشكيل حكومه كامله الصلاحيه امرا مهما
جدا لكي تستطيع كل مؤسسات الدوله ان تعمل
معا من اجل المستقبل وبرؤيه واضحه للبنان
كذلك يجب ان اقول انه ينبغي ان يكون هناك
تعاون وثيق بين البرلمان والحكومه لوضع
قوانين ملموسه وتشريعات جديده والامم
المتحده مستعده لتقديم يد المساعده نحن
مثلا نتواصل بشكل كبير مع البرلمان ونواصل
الدعم عمله ومستعدون لتقديم اراء مبتكره
وجديده خاصه العام المقبل وبقدر ما يتعلق
الامر بالمساعدات الانسانيه سنبدا برنامج
جديد في السنه القادمه
وسننشئ اطار عمل لتنميه مستدامه جديده من
اجل لبنان
في لبنان الان لابد ان تبدا من انتخاب
رئيس جديد للبلاد هناك مازق على هذا
الصعيد هل هناك اي دور او ضغوط او مساعي
للامم المتحده في اتجاه تسريع انتخاب رئيس
جديد للبلاد
هو ان اقدم خدماتي بشكل جيد الامم المتحده
معروفه بحياتها وبالتالي نحن لا نناقش
اسماء المرشحين لكننا كاصدقاء لبنان نحاول
فقط ان نشجع العمليه الديمقراطيه لان
انتخاب الرئيس ممارسه ديمقراطيه وانا اقوم
بذلك عن طريق الاتصال الوثيق مع جميع
اصحاب العلاقه في لبنان وكذلك احاول ان
اوفر بيئه جيده من الدعم من المنطقه من
خلال عرض خبرات واجراء اتصالات مع الدول
العربيه وفي المنطقه يجب ان اذكر ايضا
حقيقه ان المجتمع الدوليه متحد الى حد
كبير لاننا نود ان نرى لبنان مستهرا انا
وزملائي في الامم المتحده عندما نقدم
رسائله واضحه فاننا نتكلم لغه سحاق ونشجع
رؤيه جيده لمستقبل لبنان
الاقتصاديه المستفحله المستفحله في لبنان
يبدو المجتمع الدولي وكانه ترك لبنان
يواجه مصيره
صندوق النقد الدولي ما زال مترددا في
موضوع التقديم المساعده وكذلك دول الجوار
والدول الغربيه في هذه الحاله ملعمل
قد كان بداله
طبعا عندما نتحدث عن العقبات لابد ان نسال
اصدقاءنا اللبنانيين فهم يعرفون بشكل افضل
ما هي العقبات التي يواجهونها من اجل
اجراء اصلاحات لكن لبنان وقعت سنه الماضيه
اتفاقيه مع صندوق النقد الدولي بشروط
واضحه ومؤكده وقد بداوا فعلا بتبني بعض
القوانين على سبيل المثال قانون السريه
المصرفيه وشروط اخرى يفردها صندوق النقد
الدولي رغم ذلك هناك بعض القضايا العالقه
كمساله اصلاح النظام المصرفي واصدار قانون
بشان السيطره على رؤوس الاموال هناك
معايير يستخدمها صندوق النقد الدولي وهذه
تعد بدايه وبعد الاستجابه لكل الشروط نامل
في يوم هاه ان يوقع لبنان اتفاقا كاملا مع
صندوق النقد الدولي وهذا سيمهد الطريق
لمزيد من التمويل من جانب الصندوق ومن دول
المنطقه ايضا الحب الرشيد هو امر مطلوب
الى حد كبير لانه اذا تحققت هذه الانجازات
في لبنان من قبل جميع الاطراف وعلى كل
المستويات سوف يستطيع لبنان ان يستعيد
الثقه من جديد وهذا امر ضروري جدا لكي
يتحمس الشعب من جديد لاجل بلاده
رجاله ان توزي
شكرا
للامم المتحده في لبنان كنت معنا من روما
شكرا جزيلا